I've definitely you know gained a few
pounds over this quarantine time and I
love my body and I'm proud of you know
my shape
Kourtney Kardashian is proud of her body
no matter what the haters say on
Wednesday the 40 year old reality star
posted a video to her lifestyle brand
pushes YouTube and the mom of three
opened up about protecting herself from
cyberbullying specifically all the
people commenting on her body saying she
looks like she's pregnant again I
commented back and said this is the
shape of my body
I've definitely you know gained a few
pounds over this quarantine time and I
love my body and I'm proud of you know
my shape and I'm obviously posting it
and this is the shape of my body I don't
think I look pregnant at all we're all
shaped differently and that's my body
and I'm proud of it so that's how I
respond to the negative comments yeah
when the reality star posted the snap
last month the comments section lit up
with people speculating that she had a
baby on board so many of the comments
were like are you pregnant baby number
four pregnant pregnant but during an
insta live at court admitted she can't
be bothered with the hate I could have
taken that you know offensively and
really pin you know like oh my gosh do I
look pregnant but instead I knew that I
didn't look pregnant in my opinion I've
been pregnant three times I know what my
body looks like when I'm pregnant in the
new video for Poosh Kourtney said she's
just trying to focus on all the sweet
stuff people have to say I think we tend
to focus on the negative and I notice
for myself like a lot of questions like
the negative questions stand out to me
where I just want to respond to those
people sometimes even more than the
positive ones which isn't isn't always
fair and when all else fails court says
she tries to live by one simple rule
think killing with
kindness is kind of my motto and try to
not really let those comments affect you
and if they do then I think and you know
that just don't look at comments and I
know it's easier said than done but to
really try to just keep the positivity
and for your mental health court has
been all about protecting her peace
lately in April she announced she's
stepping back a bit from the family's
hit reality show I have decided to take
a big step back from filming and really
just pick and choose what I will allow
cameras to follow something she teased
to ET back in October you mentioned that
you might be ready to say goodbye to
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there and
still but I'm not saying goodbye do you
think the show can continue going if you
lose a sister yeah I mean we definitely
love Courtney and we will miss Courtney
and whatever she decides to do but
people come people go all the time this
family we are feel like it's a revolving
door so party you might leave this week
she'll be back they all come back
[Music]